memento mori the story goes that in
ancient Rome whenever a general would
return from battle successfully having
triumphed over his enemies and gone
through a conquest of massive
proportions they would throw a parade
for him in his army but something really
unusual that they did which as far as I
know they don't do today which is that
as the general was standing there on his
chariot looking at all of the
festivities and and soaking in all of
the praise and honor that comes from
being a victorious general there would
be right beside him on the chariot a
special person a slave actually who was
appointed there to stand there beside
him and that slave had only one job all
he had to do was to continually repeat
in the generals ears that phrase memento
mori
it wasn't meant to be more I mean well
you might be able to guess what it means
memento is aware that we've carried over
into English and it has to do with your
memory remembering things and more I it
comes from the same group where we get
post mortem which means you know after
death the phrase memento mori means
remember you are mortal
what
let's remember you're mortal why would
there be a slave appointed whose sole
job is just to whisper in the ears of
this victorious general remember you are
mortal and you know it doesn't actually
take that much thought to realize what
it was about
that's they was there and those words
within it to remind the general that
even burn that instant in time you know
especially with the way that the Roman
religions and on Pantheon worked you
know there was kind of discontinuity
with divinity and humanity that you know
people could be considered as gods they
were half gods and all that kind of
thing in that moment where all of this
honor and praise and glory was being
laid upon this general where it looks it
would be tempting to believe that if an
if anyone at any moment were a god this
would be it
the slave was there to remind that
general no no remember you're not a god
you're mortal even though this moment is
glorious and amazing and you are
powerful having you know won this war
and you are still a human being just
like the rest of us and death will come
for you just like it comes for everyone
else including those enemies you've just
vanquished now this really interests me
that our culture of ancient culture even
the culture whose capital city they
called the Eternal City even though it
very much it was not like even a culture
like that recognized that it was
important to reckon with the reality of
this is interesting to me because it
seems like the very opposite of what
modern culture does today it's a sort of
contemporary thing to not just not think
about death but to actively avoid even
even considering you're looking at it so
you know for instance I'll hold up
you know cosmetic surgery and all these
creams and hair dyes and all that kind
of thing seems to be part of our
collective desire to not want to look
old and to put away the reality that
death is coming for all of us that we
age and then we die it's not something
that we like to think about it I'm
supposed to understand why you were
matter
but today I had the opportunity and the
privilege really to attend a funeral I
didn't know the man who had passed away
but I very good friends with his wife
and a funeral is a really interesting
sort of thing obviously it's very sad
there's a lot of warm ocean flying
around but it's also a really important
time to stop and consider and think and
reflect on things like mortality
despite there not being really that old
I've been to I feel like my fair share
of fuels and even though this kind of
it's this big gathering of people and in
some ways like a wedding it's a
gathering of people who are all all are
connected to this one person and so the
all the people who gather are not
necessarily all that well connected
maybe they haven't seen each other for a
long time and so it's kind of tempting
to say AHA look there's all these people
haven't seen for ages when I talk to
them and see how they've been in catch
up but for me
and maybe because I've had some my early
experiences with funerals were very
personal they weren't just you know for
someone out there when I was 18 I went
to my mother's funeral and was an
integral part of that I've always found
funeral as a really important time just
to stop and I'm not necessarily chat or
talk away but to remember and reflect on
the fact that death is real that death
is coming for all of us and one of the
things which I effected on today is that
even though we like to think otherwise
and we use all kinds of language to say
it for instance you know instead of a
funeral being about you know necessarily
grieving it's about celebrating a life
that was and that's true that's
important that's really valid and it's I
think it's really valuable actually to
consider a funeral partly as a positive
thing I know what it's like when you
know a funeral is as much mourning the
end as well as sort of a sigh of relief
in our age you know death can come
slowly for people and that's part of the
fact that we have really good health
care and so people who might have died
suddenly or very quickly in previous
ages now take much longer to die and I
know that sounds really negative but
it's a reality that actually you know
that's suffering drawn out can be a
really awful thing to not just go
through but to watch a loved one go
through so you know it can be very much
a sigh of relief to say yes this
suffering which has been intense for so
long but for so many months or even
years is finally over so it's important
to recognize those positive aspects but
at the same time I feel like we missed
something
when we don't simply allow ourselves to
admit the death is wrong there's a
tragedy it's it's not supposed to be
this way I used to think Vina I lost my
mother when I was relatively young at
least in water terms I used to think
it's kind of a tragedy when
lose your parents or you lose anyone
sorry my disappearance when you lose
anyone before their time so if they're
very young perhaps if they died from an
accident before they get struck by some
kind of illness which is unusual as
opposed to old age but then I realized
the longer I are interacting with people
with saw saw people I knew friends
colleagues relatives go through
experience the death of loved ones where
those loved ones for all intents and
purposes live what you might call a full
life even when those people are very old
death was just as much a tragedy in some
ways I don't know how to word this
properly but I for those people who I
know who lost their parents is the most
common one parents in old age rather
than when they were young in some ways
that lost is all the more bitter because
that relationship has deepened over so
much longer this probably sounds a bit
awful but because I lost my mother when
I was young I didn't get to know her as
well as many people who who are my age
now know their parents I was pretty
lousy son I think in that journey my
high school years I suppose like many
adolescence I just didn't really want to
have anything to do with my parents and
I thought they didn't understand me and
I didn't understand them and so it just
didn't really get along and so losing my
mother when I was in my first year of
uni didn't have the time for I didn't
make myself grow up and actually
appreciate my parents which often
happens funnily enough when we ourselves
become parents and it
but what this taught me was that yes
losing your parents at a young age is
tragic but losing your parents when
they're old is also tragic doesn't make
it better it's it's it's very very
little comfort that you can say oh who I
had an extra 30 40 50 years with them
death itself the end of life is a is
wrong it's not meant to be like that as
I was sitting there in the chapel
waiting for the funeral to begin as you
can probably imagine it brought back a
whole flood of memories from when I was
younger and when my mother passed away
it was really a lot of really sort of
angry sort of person but I was very
frustrated and disappointed in my
friends because not all of them but some
of them and not just friends but
relatives in fact a whole range of
people who I'd expect it to be more
understanding or at least be more caring
and they weren't that's not to say that
people weren't understanding were caring
vast majority of people were and yet
there are a few experiences that stuck
in my mind which really hurt me
for instance there was one friend who at
university I missed weeks of university
I just just couldn't go back I applied
for exemptions from assessments and
exams and all that kind of thing and
after many weeks I returned and I sort
of expected people to say oh you know
what happened or what was the matter or
or I'm sorry you know I heard have you
lost that kind of thing and there was
one friend of mine who was in my
computing course and when he said hello
to me the first time I saw him again it
was like nothing had ever happened and
when he didn't say anything you didn't
make any sort of advance to say because
I actually didn't know for a fact that
others of my friends had told him what
had happened in my life
rather than say us I'm really starting
to hear that or you know that must be
really terrible for you
he almost acted as if it was no big deal
and just moved on of it and just started
talking about our assignments that we
had to do had to that we had to work on
and I was really hurt by that I couldn't
understand why someone would be sir I
viewed it at the time as really
insensitive and callous and unfeeling
and just totally unsympathetic and
always frustrated by that a lot I also
had well-meaning friends who would talk
to me and say and try and encourage me
basically and I would say you know
things like you know she's in a better
place now or things like you know she'd
be so proud of you and what you've
achieved or you know the hard things in
life are always preparing you for
they're making your character better all
these kinds of trying to see that
positive side of things facing and in
the same way I found those kinds of
words and people trying to encourage me
it's also really hurtful because the
thing was that I knew all of these
things are people telling me and they
were often encouraging me to you know
say it you don't feel so bad
try that you know keep your chin up keep
going don't be depressed about it and
even though I knew all of the things
that are telling me the emotional
reality just wasn't there and I I
couldn't make myself feel better and I
didn't need someone to tell me to make
myself feel better because I couldn't do
it so I thought to myself over the last
it's been it's been bad news though over
the last nine years what I learnt well I
think one of the things I realized was
that I expected too much of my friends
now you know if you're an 18 year old
you probably I hope haven't had to deal
that much with you death in your life
and so I now have come to see him
apologize for the fact that didn't
understand this before but most of my
friends who seems you know insensitive
or callous or unsympathetic they weren't
they weren't bad it's just that they
didn't know what to say they hadn't
dealt with it they they didn't
understand the situation and then you
didn't understand it and then you
nothing they could say could make things
better and so they resorted to what they
knew which was just to try and get on
with life as best as they could and so I
I didn't realize that about my friends I
expected too much of them and so one of
the things I want to encourage you now
if you're younger and you just haven't
encountered debt that much in your life
and perhaps you know people you know
dreaming all morning he's a helpful kind
of picture that I've heard which helps
me now even even today being much older
and having learned a lot more lessons to
to grieve well if that makes sense and
to help others to grieve well so what I
want you to a picture is the person who
you feel is most at the center of this
grief so maybe that's a husband or a
wife
father or son or daughter whoever it is
and literally get a piece of paper and
write their name in the middle of a
piece of paper all people who you feel
are closest to this tragedy then draw a
circle around them after that circle on
the outside of the circle write down the
names of people who you know who are
closest situation but not as close to
the situation as the people who you've
already written down so maybe instead of
the immediate family it might be uncles
and auntie's grandchildren or and let's
say what colleagues and so on write them
down and then after you've got it to get
those people who draw another circle and
then on the outside of that circle
write down people who you know who are
disconnected even more so for instance
people who might have known that person
met him her worked with them or you know
just had dinner with them once or
something like that
people who are further away from the
situation words would still feel that
grief
and then you can draw another circle and
you can keep on going as as far as you
like and then also finally try to work
out where you fit in in those concentric
circles so you may well be you know sort
of right on the very edge or you
somewhere in the middle or something
like that
now put your name in as well or maybe
just put a staff where you belong now
here's what helps me in in talking to
people who are going through grief if
you are talking to someone who is closer
to the center then you are okay I'm
closer to the center more connected to
the tragedy or the grief then you have
one job and only one and that is support
all you have to do is support you have
to be there for those people you don't
necessarily have to say all that much
your physical presence means a lot you
just you can offer things to them you
can try to think of practical ways that
might help them like cooking a meal all
those kinds of things that's all you do
to the people who are who are closer
into the center support that's all you
do now maybe you feel very grieved by
this situation yourself maybe you feel
like you know this person they're great
friends to feel like that
but your burdens are not meant to go to
people on the inside those people are
feeling more of a burden and more grief
than you if you have burdens and grief
and troubles which you ought to have you
should push those two people outside and
you should say the people who know them
know the person less well than you you
know I'm just finding this really hard
I'm exhausted and I I don't even know
how to cope at work now that this person
is gone or etc all of those are griefs
and burdens and difficulties they have a
place but that place is not going back
onto the people who are closer into the
situation they should be going to people
further out and stories you know for you
you know are one of the most common
sorts of reactions to stories of
difficulty in trial is we think of our
own difficulty and trial and so you know
if you have if you want to make
comparisons to your own situation you
don't do that to the people inside you
know closer to the center of the circle
because they're just feeling the grief
and struggling to come to terms with it
themselves let alone dealing with you
know you and your own problems which are
something altogether different so if you
want to talk about those talk to people
outside further out from the circle and
that'll be a way that you make sure you
don't say things that are inappropriate
or unhelpful to people if you like you
know I'm always on the outside you know
I've never actually in the inside I'm
always supporting all these other people
and pushing out my difficulties
increases to people who are further out
you know don't worry there's one thing
that's certainly life is that you're
gonna have your turn in the center of
the circle okay so I found that kind of
mental framework really helpful in
thinking about okay how do I talk to
people
grieving it's a really helpful guide one
other thought and I had while I was
sitting there listening actually to the
eulogies and the people talking about
their memories of the person who passed
away is that recognizing death and
reckoning with its reality being willing
to admit that it's a tragedy is just
wrong
recognizing death ought to make us value
life in order to make us think carefully
about what matters in life what we want
to be remembered for what we want to
remember when we're on our own our
deathbed or what we want people to say
about us at our eulogy and this is
interesting to me because just recently
I went to my 10-year high school reunion
which is a really nice time about let's
see a quarter of my grade got back
together which is nice after ten years
considering a lot of people interstate
and overseas and after 10 years 10 years
is kind of enough time for people to
have finished studying mostly sorry med
people finished studying and actually
done something with their lives go on
places done something interesting all
those kinds of things and being there
you know seeing all these people
catching up talking about all the kinds
of things that we've done was really
interesting and I really enjoyed it at
the time but now after after taking his
funeral today I now just posing the
question to myself of how much of what
my friends 10 years on after high school
how much of it will we remember or will
be worth memory on our deathbeds what
will be worth saying yes this is
something that's valuable and I achieved
and that I did for others and others
will remember we'll all of the traveling
and all of the career climbing all of
that kind of thing will that really be
valuable to us when death comes knocking
at our door now maybe the answer to that
is yes I don't know I suppose it differs
for every individual but I think the
important thing is to actually ask that
question I think too many people go
through life never considering is this
gonna be something that's worthwhile in
the long run we just do things because
the opportunity's there because we're
following what everyone else is doing
and in our culture and we're not
actually questioning whether it's going
to be something which we'd want to
remember and which we want to be
remembered for there's some thoughts I
don't know how true they are taken for
what you will but I don't know from my
two cents I think the ancient Romans
were onto something with memento mori